we all have two lives the second begins
when you realize you only have one this
is a universal experience for all
creative people certainly actors is that
the constant
rejection at the beginning you have to
get used to it and you have to
get thick-skinned about it you'll never
win
unless you also stand to lose everything
is possible and nothing is guaranteed
take pains be perfect
i think a myth in the business is that
we all have everything to choose from
is that we don't i know i'm not like top
of everybody's list
it's uh i mean it's just you have to
earn that place but you know
sometimes you might read something and
think i have read things and gone wow
this is amazing
and i've chased it down and knocked on
the door and people have said actually
it's not you tom
we're thinking of someone different and
then my job is to keep knocking on the
door and say
let me see if i can change your mind
i've been very diligent in my training
and tried to listen to the advice of all
my teachers and instructors
as a student as an academic as a
training actor and i always wanted to do
right by them
and i found myself as a very scary
moment when you're
a young actor most people find
themselves in their early 20s
and everything is possible and nothing
is guaranteed
if you're lucky enough you have an agent
and you start auditioning and they send
you everything
from period drama to
casualty to dairy milk commercials
and you are thrown into the business and
thrown into it at the deep end and
there's no time
for doubt or failure
except routinely that's what happens to
all of us um
and i was so i perhaps was too careful
in auditioning
and i would always get close to landing
roles into booking jobs and i would
never quite get there i mean
this is a universal experience for all
creative people certainly actors
is that the constant rejection at the
beginning you have to get used to it and
you have to
get thick-skinned about it i was so
exhausted
because at first you take it very
personally and
i thought well no one's gonna help me
get there the only person who could do
this is me
i started preparing in a different way
and i sort of stepped up to the place a
little better i think
because i could feel time sliding away
and i wasn't
getting on with life i just was sort of
stuck in this rut of
neither acting nor doing anything else
the experience of being in your 20s is
so energetic and i felt so
stagnant actually so i just kind of
um changed everything up and it worked
i'm lucky
i don't know that i've ever been able to
to do anything i i say it as a sort of
because i'm aware that it can be a
strength but it can also be a weakness
because the focus is
obsessive so when i go for something i
go for it at the expense of everything
else
i love what i do simply and
i feel so lucky that i'm allowed to do
it and that i'd get to do it for a
living
and cinema and theater have had such a
profound effect on me
in my life and so i always every time a
new script or a new role comes along
i'm motivated by the thought i won't
forgive myself if i don't give it
everything but i do
try to choose different kinds of things
because i'm interested in
in the diversity of people
and the complexity of people and the
multiplicity we contain within us
i really think the thing that unites us
all in the world is that we are
constantly inconstant and that
inconstancy in that contradiction is
something that i've always tried to
explore
with my characters because i think that
we contradict ourselves all the time
there's a
the walt whitman um poem the song of
myself i am large i contain multitudes
i contradict myself we all have two
lives
the second begins when you realize
you only have one so
i i'm not wasting any time and the thing
is that
you know with negativity they are like
clouds that pass across the sun
they will pass like they're just
feelings you know and it's important not
to dwell on them and just move past it
there is so much
i find maybe it's my nature but there's
just so much about life that's amazing
and when you kind of key into that
nobody has an easy right
that's for sure and it's about to get
harder i'm sure
but it also gets better and the point
about
going through those experiences is you
just have to sort of go
well it is what it is and it'll pass and
you just when you tap into like how
amazing
stuff is it's pretty cool i think
um i always trust my gut that's all i
have
even when i'm working and you're
thinking about the shape of a scene and
how it should be played and
and your head can often get in a way and
you've got to trust your gut
it's just if i'm inspired if my
curiosity is peaked
and i want to chase this possibility
down
that i see in front of me on my desk you
know it's um
some of you may have heard me say this
before but and i i always i'm
embarrassed to say i was speaking
metaphors i don't know how to speak in
any other way and for me acting is kind
of like playing the piano
and if the piano is the human condition
we all have
every single note on that 88 key
board within us for me
every role i want to be able to play
every note and some
and sometimes if a character or a story
seems to
seem to stretch me in some way seems to
to to offer up an experience
that is new that is a different chord or
a different tune
that is real and true and human and
accessible and
no matter how joyous or or or loving or
warm or how dark or painful if it seems
like an interesting shape to inhabit i'm
running i know if i'm running towards it
already
i think it's a quote from shakespeare um
which is i have
four words take pains
be perfect i think his way of saying you
know
don't be afraid of caring i gave myself
permission
to care because there are a lot of
people in this world
who are afraid of caring or afraid of
showing that they care because
it's uncool it's uncool to have passion
it's so much easier to lose
when you've shown everyone how much you
don't care if you win or lose
it's much harder to lose when you show
that you care
but you'll never win unless you also
stand to lose
basically you know i've said it before
don't be afraid of your passion
like just give it free reign be honest
and work hard and it'll all turn out
just fine when i was at drama school
drama school was really hard they
deliberately kind of overwork you
and they just throw you they throw
everything at you and maybe i was
i was on a three-year course in at a
drama school in london
called rada and um the first year you
kind of work you sort of
sort of slightly showing your strengths
and the things that you're good at and
the second year they throw you
everything you can't do
all the things that are your weaknesses
and you're basically to work on your
weaknesses what's the point you're
working on your strengths
you're working 16 hour days and you're
exhausted and you're drained and you're
physically tired and
i i kind of lost the love a bit i lost
my mojo
i live um near a couple of parks in
london i remember
i just one night i couldn't sleep and i
was the summer i got up really early in
the morning and i went
and walked to the nearest big hill and i
saw the sun rising
sometimes like that's the answer is just
get up when the sun gets up and look
around
and and you realize you're part of an
amazing
planet that's what i do
you